Donald Trump abruptly rage quit his own press
briefing yesterday after a historically embarrassing
implosion, even by Trump's own standards.
I've essentially stopped covering the press
briefings and the roundtables and the propaganda
events on the podcast and the broadcast show
because they're just trash.
I mean, there's simply disinformation.
There's no news.
They are worthless at communicating policy
in any significant way.
They've also been going on a lot less frequently
ever since Trump wondered aloud about injecting
bleach to treat Corona virus.
But yesterday, Trump scheduled one.
And it is really worth telling you what happened.
I'm going to skip right to the questions part
of the presentation.
I can sum up as we're the best on testing
and the envy of the world with that out of
the way.
Let's get to the questions.
We're gonna start with the build up about
Obama gate.
We'll go to the climax where Trump tells an
Asian reporter to ask China.
And then the day new mom where Trump abruptly
walks off, furious that a CNN reporter tried
to ask a question.
So we'll start with Philip Rucker.
Philip is White House bureau chief at The
Washington Post, also wrote a book that very
much triggered Donald Trump called The Very
Stable Genius.
Rucker is really good at framing questions
in a way that directly expose Trump's non-answers.
Trump's been tweeting about so-called Obama
gate.
Trump tweeted it in all caps with no explanation.
Over the weekend, also claiming that the Obama
administration and Obama himself committed
the biggest political crime in American history.
Here is Philip Rucker expertly asking Trump,
Which crime did Barack Obama commit?
What law did he break?
Trump glitches, freezes and simply repeats
Obamacare.
Obama gate is the crime.
Take a look.
Mr. President, in one of your mother tweets.
You appear to accused President Obama of the
biggest political crime in American history
by far.
Those were your words.
What crime exactly are you accusing President
Obama of committing?
And do you believe the Justice Department
should prosecute him?
Obama again.
It's been going on for a long time.
It's been going on from before I even got
elected.
And it's a disgrace that it happened.
And if you look at what's gone on and if you
look at now all of this information that's
being released, and from what I understand,
that's only the beginning.
Some terrible things happened and it should
never be allowed to happen in our country
again.
OBAMA Gator's the crime, my friends.
Now, Philip Rucker tries to follow up, of
course.
Now, I looked at the U.S. code of law.
I couldn't find Obama gate. as a crime because
it doesn't exist.
Trump has no idea what he's talking about.
Here's the follow up from Philip Rucker.
And you'll be seeing what's going on over
the next over the coming weeks.
But I wish you'd write honestly about it,
but unfortunately, you choose not to do so.
Yeah.
John, please.
What is the crime exactly that you keeping?
You know what the crime is?
The crime is very obvious to everybody.
All you have to do is read the newspapers
except yours.
John, please.
Mr. President, this is a child.
Ladies and gentlemen, this is a child.
So next, let's go to CBS News reporter Wagih
Jiang.
Friend of the show.
Also extremely proficient at getting Trump
to blow his stack.
She asks, why are you always bragging about
testing?
Like, why?
Whether it's true or not.
Why is this a competition when people are
dying?
People continue to die and Trump doesn't like
it.
He flips out and says, why don't you go ask
that question to China?
Go ahead, please.
Many times that the US is doing far better
than any other country when it comes to testing.
Yes.
Why does that matter?
Why is this a global competition to you if
every day Americans are still losing their
lives and we're still seeing more cases every
day?
Well, they're losing their lives everywhere
in the world.
And maybe that's a question you should ask
China.
Don't ask me.
Has China that question?
OK, when you ask them that question, you may
get a very unusual answer.
Yes.
Behind you, please.
So this already makes no sense before we even
get to the Asian component of it.
The question was, why is this a competition
on testing while people died says go ask China.
Ask them what?
I don't hear the Chinese president saying
we have the most and best tests or we've defeated
the invisible scourge.
Then it gets really wild when Wagih, a Giang
who is Asian, says, why are you asking me
to go talk to China?
Why?
Why me, sir?
Why are you saying that to me specifically?
I'm telling you, I'm not saying it specifically
to anybody.
I'm saying that anybody would ask a nasty
question like that and asked, please go ahead.
Why is it OK?
Anybody else?
So is this something about Wagih Jiang being
Asian-American?
I don't know.
With Trump, you never know.
But it's all just wacky.
It's cartoonish.
It's a comedy of errors.
And this really has Trump riled for the last
bit of it.
The last pillar of the three headed monster
for Trump or the equivalent of Trump's kryptonite
when being asked questions, is made up of
Philip Rucker, Wagih Jiang and lastly, CNN's
Caitlin Collins.
She gets up to ask a question.
Trump called on her right before Wagih a Jang's
follow up.
I guess she didn't react quickly enough by
allowing Wagin to follow up and Trump rage
quits and walks out of the room or back into
the White House.
Better said.
OK, everybody else, please go ahead.
The best place to go.
It's OK for me.
I have two questions for next next class that
you did.
You called on me.
I did.
And you didn't respond.
And now I'm calling.
I'm sorry.
I just.
The young lady in the back, please.
I just wanted to let my colleague.
We can ask.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
I can't tell if at the head there you hear
someone say what or if that's something else.
But what a moment.
What an implosion.
And this is why he's been cutting the briefings,
because they're an increasingly embarrassing
disaster.
Imagine any other president, Republican or
Democrat, rage quitting after acting this
childishly.
So the Weegee a Jan part, Caitlin Collins
part.
These are more about Trump's wacky behavior.
He's clearly very afraid of Caitlin Collins
asking questions.
OK.
The really crucial part here is Trump claiming
Obama perpetrated a crime.
Presidents accusing former presidents of crimes
is a big deal.
Being asked what crime was committed is logical
and being unable to say this is what the crime
was is particularly problematic.
Now, you may surmise that there is no evidence
that Obama committed a crime that Donald Trump
is trying to accuse him of.
Trump is clearly desperate to take attention
off of the virus and instead go after Obama
for something, anything.
And we've got to watch this very closely,
because we've seen Trump's Justice Department
say they're not going to prosecute a guy who
pleaded guilty, Michael Flynn.
They are now emboldened and they're liable
to really be out there with this Obama crime
stuff.
So we'll keep following it, including on our
Instagram account.
Make sure you are following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
And while you're there with peace and love,
follow me on Instagram as well.
I am.
David got attacked on Instagram.